[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى موجز الاخبار من الجزيره وقع
عدد من القوى المدنيه ومجلس السياده
السوداني اتفاقا سياسيا ايطاليا يؤسس
لمرحله انتقاليه مدتها 24 شهر ينص
والاتفاق على ان المرحله الانتقاليه تبدا
من تاريخ تعيين رئيس الوزراء وتنتهي
باجراء انتخابات عامه ياتي ذلك بعد اكثر
من عام من الاحتجاجات في السودان
وتعالى رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان عبد
الفتاح البرهان بمعالجه اخطاء النظام
السابق بشان المؤسسه العسكريه وفي مقابله
مع الجزيره اضاف البرهان ان الاتفاق
الايطاليه مفتوح لكل القوى الثوريه غير
الموقعه عليه وانه لائق
بدوره وصف نائب رئيس مجلس السياده محمد
حمدان حميطي قرار الاستيلاء على السلطه في
الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر بالخطا
السياسيه الذي فتح الباب على الانقسامات
في تونس اكد المتحدث باسم حركه النهضه ان
ما سماها سلطه الانقلاب فشلت في ادارته
جميع ملفات الاجتماعيه والسياسيه
واضافانا الانتخابات التشريعيه المرتقبه
الشهر الجريس تعمق الازمه الدستوريه في
البلاد ويتراقب وشارع التونسي
وجبهه الخلاص مقاطعه الانتخابات
قصفت القوات الروسيه هو العاصمه تركيب
وخرسون وزباروجين وميكو لايف بوابل من
الصواريخ وهو ما تسبب في انقطاع تيار
الكهربائي على نطاق واسع وقال الرئيس
الاوكراني من الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت معظم
الصواريخ وان التيار الكهربائيه سيعود
تدريجيا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اندفاعتها
الجويه تتصدت لهجوم اوكراني بمسيرات سوريه
الصنع على مطرين عسكريين في وسطي وجنوب
البلاد واوضح المتحدث ان 13 يخرون
دخل قرار مجموعه هي السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي واستراليا تحديدا سقفي السعر
واردات النفط الروسيه المنقوله بحرا دخل
حيزه تنفيذ امس الاثنين وبذلك هيبداوا
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول مجموعه السبعه
العمله بحضر وليدات الروسي
النفط الروسيه المنقوله بحرا وبينما حذر
المتحدث باسم الكرملين من ان الاجراءات
سيؤدي الى زعزعه استقرار السوق الطاقه
في واشنط على منسق والاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه للبيت الابيض جون كربي ان
الولايات المتحده تريد استقرار سعر النفط
في السوق العالميه واستبعد حدوث تداعيات
بعيده المدى على الاسعار العالميه
[موسيقى]
انتهى الموجز السلام عليكم